Now it's time for
you to think about a product idea.
One you'll use throughout
the rest of this course.
>> Yeah and
if you don't have an idea already,
think about problems in your
life that you want to solve.
If nothing comes in mind
check out requests for
startups in the instructor notes.
Is there an industry that
you always think about?
You can also observe others and their
work and talk to them about the problems
that they face or
the problems that there companies face.
The best problems to address are those
that you have personal experiences with.
Your commitment to finding a solution
will be that much stronger and
it will be the one thing that keeps
you going through the crazy highs and
the crazy lows of building a company.
>> It's a key idea to make sure
that you're building something
that solves a real problem.
Yeah, for example Apoorva Mehta, the
founder of Instacart and his cofounder.
They spent a year and a half trying to
build a social network for lawyers,
without realizing one cardinal
truth about the space.
And that's that,
lawyers don't like to share.
Apoorva eventually solved
a different problem.
And it was one that he always thought
was a personal pain, grocery shopping.
He realized that his friends were
willing to use the app that he built,
and it was unlike so
many of his other products.
>> By observing and
reflecting on the world around you,
you'll be likely to stumble
upon an idea that you love.